muito bom dia as senhoras e senhores
sejam bem vindos a bordo
eu vou falar sobre
e cair e levantar esse tema pode parecer
estranho vindo de um piloto de avião e
ele de fato é o avião e cair
não combino desde muito pequeno eu gosto
de aviões quando passava um era aquela
criança que dizia o avião um avião e eu
ficava por horas
o tempo passou e isso não mudou até hoje
o som do avião não é um som normal
muitas crianças gostam de avião e elas
dizem que querem ser piloto quando
crescer eu acho que elas desistem quando
elas descobrem que o avião pode cair
alguém aqui sonhou em ser piloto quando
era criança
alguém aqui tem medo de voar hoje as
pesquisas mostram que entre 40 e 60 por
cento das pessoas têm medo de voar
há quem diga que não tem medo porque se
for acontecer alguma coisa não vai poder
fazer absolutamente nada
há quem diga que não tem medo hoje mais
um dia já teve
afinal de contas o medo é instintivo
para contrariar as pesquisas
as estatísticas apontam que a cada 10
milhões de decolagens apenas quatro
acidentes acontecem
o avião é o meio de transporte mais
seguro que existe mas eu quero ver
pensar isso quando estava dentro e
começa aquela turbulência
a gente se agarrar no banco da poltrona
por mais que isso não vai adiantar de
nada
a evolução do vôo foi muito rápida e
assim como a evolução de diversas
tecnologias
ela teve momentos em determinados pontos
eram aceitáveis e logo depois se
tornaram absurdos
o homem sempre quis voar conseguiu isso
apenas no início do século 20 e 25 anos
depois já usava o avião nas guerras e
quarenta anos depois havia o transporte
aéreo de passageiros regular naquilo que
há uma grande aventura
em 1960 um avião decolava de porto
alegre para nova york que demorava quase
três dias e dificilmente chegava lá com
os mesmos motores que tinha saído daqui
de porto alegre e acontecendo falhas de
motor durante
o os motores vão sendo substituídos mas
ninguém deixava de voar naquela época
por causa disso isso é uma coisa normal
o fato é que essa reação que a gente tem
hoje comercial que a gente vê nos
aeroportos ela tem em si segurança
altíssimos e ela consegue aprendendo com
os erros que comete mas estou certo que
você já viu no jornal acidentes e de
outras avaliações aviação geral a gestão
agrícola ea viação de instrução a gente
junta tudo no mesmo pacote e fala que
são os aviões pequenos né
essas ações têm insegurança um pouco
diferente e é por elas que nós pilotos
começamos nossas carreiras comigo não
foi diferente
até o ensino médio o meu caminho na
minha cabeça era uma linha reta
eu saí do colégio e entrar no clube
companhia aérea com o piloto comandante
barbada sucesso total
ao final do terceiro ano eu descobri que
meus pais enxergavam uma curva de
conhecimento no meu caminho e essa curva
era chamada de gestão para inovação e
liderança
era um curso novo à época e eu fiquei
bastante contrariado mas hoje eu acho
que isso foi excelente
ainda mais porque com essa aparência eu
não ia muito longe na aviação treino gil
é comecei a cursar faculdade achei
demais fiz grandes amigos aprendi um
monte mas os aviões nunca voaram para
longe da metade da faculdade eu fiz um
intercâmbio prolongado é umas férias
prolongadas fiz um intercâmbio para os
estados unidos com um único objetivo que
era juntar dinheiro pra virar piloto
tive três empregos ao mesmo tempo eu fui
salva vidas de piscina térmica
pressionar um pouco maior que essa
eu fui barista numa cafeteria também é
mais ou menos barista e foi
recepcionista de hotel
cheguei a trabalhar há 68 dias seguidos
e voltei para o brasil com aquilo que eu
achava que era um monte de dinheiro pra
virar piloto eu precisava de no mínimo
170 horas com aquele monte de dinheiro e
tinha voado e tinha feito 35 horas
ali a minha chance piloto
muito remota até que no dia da minha
formatura meu padrinho me ajudou a
voltar à trajetória inicial
ele ofereceu ajuda nas horas de vôo fiz
todas as horas de voo e eu acho que até
hoje eu não soube agradecer que chega
por isso larguei todos os empregos que
tinha na administração formado em
administração e virou instrutor de vôo
fui da instrução não era o clube de bagé
lá no interior do estado chegando a o
presidente disse eduardo é tem aqui 15
cachorros trazendo mais segurança na
zona rural de bagé tem um avião em
funcionamento e três alunos dentro
alongar tinha uma cama e aí eu morava e
aquilo pra mim era disparado o melhor
emprego do mundo eu voava de dia e de
noite comer churrasco neste rascunho eu
conheci aviação agrícola
esse diversos e 12 conhecer ação
agressiva aviação agrícola é a
pulverização de lavouras feira por
aviões que é feita para combater e
prevenir as pragas na lavoura
esses aviões passam a baixa altura
rápidos e aplicar os produtos que são
necessários ao final de cada faixa de
pulverização o avião faz uma curva de
reversão
quanto mais tempo o avião fica
pulverizando mais eficiente o trabalho
dessa forma à curva de reversão deve ser
otimizada
ao final da curva ao final da faixa o
piloto inicia uma curva ascendente ea
retomada volta para o chão pra seguir na
próxima faixa volta pro chão bem próximo
à obra é semiautomático os pilotos que
fazem essa reação agrícola são muito
habilidosos e eles garantem a qualidade
dos alimentos que a gente recebe a mesa
trabalhando durante a safra de sol a sol
foi em bagé também que tive contato com
o primeiro acidente da aviação agrícola
um piloto que era tido por eles como o
melhor o mais habilidoso se acidentou um
fio de alta tensão deve ter pensado a
mesma coisa que alguns de vocês será que
passa um avião em baixo um filho
atenção o fato é que passa e isso é uma
coisa bem normal hoje
comecei a conhecer um pouco de
estatísticas de segurança de vôo e
acabei entrando pra ela eu ia entrando
pra dentro dela e eu de fato entrei pra
dentro dela é tudo ia muito bem e é
baseado em uma tarde de domingo meu
aluno me ligou e zé eduardo
vamos fazer um golzinho eu falei que
certo foi até o lugar onde o avião
estava sem gasolina
ele fernando não venha não tem gasolina
daqui a pouco ele me ligou os 15 minutos
depois eduardo conseguir um balão na
aviação agrícola ainda foi então vem
fui pra fora ou leio vejo como cruzado
harlei ernando não vem daqui a pouco
vento diminuiu fernando vem aquela tive
cinco finais que eu não devia decolar
eu era apaixonado olha sou apaixonada
não tava nem aí pelos sinais agente
decolou o avião aquele bem pequenininha
que cabe uma estrutura atrás do aluno na
frente
cheguei a ver o chão é o passe logo
depois da decolagem passeio controles
para ele e peguei um rádio pra começar a
falar eu comecei a falar embaixo do
painel dele sair uma cortina de fumaça
essa cortina de fumaça girava no teto
veio na minha direção
a primeira coisa que eu pensei foi na
minha mãe a minha mãe dizia onde tem
fumaça tem fogo
a segunda coisa que eu pensei também não
foi nada aeronáutica a minha trajetória
chegar lá na frente como andam de avião
grande internacional
aquilo não estava prevista o fato é que
tinha 1 194 horas totais das quais 171
sido sob supervisão para minha 24ª hora
de comandante e eu estava com um avião
pegando fogo e eu tinha que fazer alguma
coisa
demorei 22 anos para entender que um
avião pode cair
só que não dava mais tempo têm medo ou
fazer alguma coisa ou não fazia mais
nada
a última coisa que me lembro foi quando
a última árvore o motor tinha parado e o
aluno fernando ele olhou para trás e ele
conta que eu botei a mão no ombro dele
falei fica tranquila vou tirar a gente
dessa
por mais medo que eu estivesse sentindo
isso mostra um pouco de coragem eu tinha
a gente caiu a gente mas com bastante
fernando bem mais porque ele estava no
banco da frente e bateu com o rosto no
painel e hoje quando eu olho para as
fotos
quando olho pra mim depois acidente já
tinha perdido o cabelo e eu também né
quando eu olho para o fernando eu acho
que o procedimento foi razoável
agora quando eu olho para o avião eu
acho que o procedimento foi excelente
porque o avião virou um churrasco de
desagradável
eu descobri com o acidente que as
pessoas julgam acidentes aéreos
normalmente a gente julga acidentes
aéreos do piloto morto
e esse não é o meu caso eu estava vivo
escutando julgamento
o meus amigos me ajudar me chamavam de o
barbeiro dos ares ou ainda o maneta dos
ares
lá em bagé todo mundo me deu um apoio
enorme mas a gente dá mais bola pra quem
critica eu me lembro muito bem de um
cara que chegou lá e sim focar agora
destruir o avião do aeroclube
como é que a gente vai continuar da
instrução uma coisa ficou na minha
cabeça depois daquele o fracasso se
instalou o meu sonho de voar tinha
virado um pesadelo terrível porque eu
nunca mais é ter o mesmo número de
decolagens e pousos
eu sempre estaria com uma decolagem mais
decidi encarar o acidente como um
tropeço e não como uma queda e deixei a
minha mãe com menos cabelos que eu mude
quando 30 dias depois eu voltei para o
clube e fiz o meu primeiro vôo solo pela
segunda vez
logo depois me chamaram eu podia agora
do sul eu trabalhei mais um ano e hoje
há cinco anos eu sou piloto uma empresa
aqui no brasil tem o meu sonho de voar
realizado e de fato acho a máquina que
eu vou maravilhosa mas acidente o
acidente nunca foi para longe na minha
cabeça e os jornais ajudaram nisso
sempre fotos como essas aparecem
eu lembro que um dia e
estava lá dentro é é mesmo assim a
primeira vez que eu vi um drone aqueles
dois pequenininhos branquinho que tiram
fotos
eu não pensei em nenhum útil nenhum uso
pra ele nesse setor mas não demorou
muito no período de férias pra que eu e
meu sócio christian a gente pensasse no
uso do nip para pulverização agrícola
a gente começou a pesquisar e descobrir
o que já existe muitos drone a gente tem
muitas drogas de monitoramento das
lavouras
mas a idéia não era essa idéia a
organização mesmo e pra isso encontramos
um produto semelhante parecido no japão
mas nada nem parecido
é uma coisa que a gente viu que se diz
que um drone de pulverização agrícola
ele é ruim porque ele tira lhe o emprego
dos pilotos
eu achei um conceito totalmente errado e
é um conceito de quem não conhece
aviação agrícola
o drone não carrega o peso que o avião
carrega
dessa forma o drone pode fazer todas as
partes sensíveis da lavoura por partes
sensíveis
eu quero dizer aquelas onde ano após ano
os relatórios de acidente mostram que os
acidentes se repetem perda de controle
no ar falha de motor e colisão com
obstáculos
todos os anos os pilotos morrem sob
essas condições
hoje em dia é aceitável que um piloto
passa a 300 por hora entre uma cerca e
um fio de alta tensão
hoje em dia aceitava o piloto acabou o
seu expediente abrir o motor mexer no
que precisa
no dia seguinte fazer uma obra cima para
baixo e que precisa do máximo daquele
motor
eu tenho uma esperança de que logo logo
isso vai virar um absurdo
além de melhorar a segurança a
pulverização com drone permite uma
eficiência muito melhor porque o avião
tem que fazer aquela curva de reversão
que é estimado em 25 segundos
o drone não precisa além disso as falhas
que o avião deixa que não são por
incompetência os pilotos elas são sim
por insegurança do piloto entrar com um
avião naquela posição ela também não vão
acontecer se o drone cair nada
somado a tudo isso todos os cálculos até
agora me mostram que há uma redução no
custo
o pulverizado quando se faz isso com um
drone um veículo não tripulado
eu tenho uma esperança que num futuro
bem próximo a gente consiga entrar nas
lavouras como avião e drone cada um
fazendo o seu melhor
falando em futuro meu filme preferido
quando era pequeno era o de volta para o
futuro
acho que vocês lembram esse filme
esse filme um cientista muito louco e um
jovem representante do jeito americanos
e aprontava das confusões entre o futuro
passado e presente ele tinha uma máquina
do tempo e essa máquina do tempo mudar o
futuro deles
o que eu aprendi nesse filme é que a
máquina do tempo não mudava nada quem
mudava o futuro deles eram eles mesmos a
máquina do tempo era um instrumento para
que eles fossem até o futuro entender se
as relações de causa e efeito do que
eles fizeram aqui
dessa forma eu entendo que a gente pode
mudar o futuro da gente simplesmente
mudando as relações de causa e efeito do
que eu faço hoje aqui é um presente um
projeto drone agrícola eo essa
maravilhosa máquina do tempo chamada dia
de hoje para tentar mudar e melhorar um
futuro bem próximo
a gente só não pode mudar o futuro ou a
morte
tive uma chance de ficar viúvo e hoje
identifica uma oportunidade de melhorar
a vida cotidiana de um monte de gente
o projeto de lei agrícola está decolando
está em fase de testes durante os testes
acontecem muitas falhas e essas falhas
pra gente significam quedas mas as
quedas não são mais importantes porque o
importante mesmo é aprender a levantar
muito obrigado